los peruanos saldrán nuevamente a las
calles para repudiar al parlamento por
destituir al presidente al presidente de
martín vizcarra y poner en su lugar a
manuel merino para lo que es este la
capital en lima se ha citado una gran
movilización a la plaza san martín esto
ha sido a través de las redes sociales
se iniciará la marcha a partir de la 2
de la tarde en cambio en otros sectores
de la capital se realizarán
movilizaciones a partir de las 4 la idea
es una nueva estrategia que han tomado
los manifestantes realizar
movilizaciones descentralizadas que les
permitan llevar mayor personas a las
protestas los
y que participan los organizadores se
han señalado que ellos no van a dar
tregua en las calles con las protestas
hasta forzar la renuncia de manuel
merino